so in single variable calculus if you
have a function f of X and you want to
find the maximum or the minimum of this
function what you do is you find its
derivative and you set that equal to
zero and graphically this has the
interpretation that you know if you have
the graph of f setting its derivative
equal to zero means that you're looking
for places where it's got a flat tangent
line so in the graph that I drew it
would be these two flat tangent lines
and then once you find these points you
know for example here you have one
solution that I'll call x1 and then here
you have another solution x2 you can ask
yourself the question are these maxima
or are they minima right because both of
these can have a flat tangent lines so
when you do find this and you want to
understand is it a maximum or a minimum
if you're just looking at the graph we
can tell you know you can tell that this
point here is a local maximum and this
point here is a local minimum but if you
weren't looking at the graph there's a
nice a nice test that will tell you the
answer you basically look for the second
second derivative and in this case
because the concavity is down that
second derivative is going to be less
than zero and then over here because the
concavity is up that second derivative
is greater than zero and by getting this
information of the concavity you can
make a conclusion that when the
concavity is down you're at a local
maximum when the concavity is up you're
at a local minimum and in the case where
the second second derivative is zero
it's undetermined you you would have to
do more tests to figure it out it's
unknown so in the multi variable world
this situation is very similar as I've
talked about in previous videos what
what you do is you'd you'd have some
kind of function and let's say it's a
two variable function and instead of
looking for where the derivative equals
zero you're going to be looking for
where the gradient of your function is
equal to the zero vector which we might
make bold to emphasize that that's a
vector and that corresponds with finding
flat tangent planes and if that seems
unfamiliar go back and take a look at
the video where I introduce the idea of
multivariable maxima and minima but the
subject of this video is going to be on
what is analogous to this second
derivative test we're in the single
variable world you just find the second
derivative and check if it's greater
than or less than zero how
we in the multi variable world do
something similar to figure out if you
have a local minimum a local maximum or
that new possibility of a saddle point
that I talked about in the last video so
there is another test and it's called
the second a partial derivative test and
I'll get to the specifics of that at the
very end of this video but to set the
landscape I want to actually talk
through a specific example where we're
finding when the gradient equals zero
just to see what that looks like and
just to have some concrete formulas to
deal with so the function that you're
looking at right now is f of X Y is
equal to X to the fourth minus four x
squared plus y squared okay so that's
the function that we're dealing with and
in order to find where its tangent plane
is flat we're looking for where the
gradient equals zero and remember this
is just really a way of unpacking the
requirements that both partial
derivatives the partial derivative of F
with respect to X at some point and what
kind of write it in is where we're
looking for the x and y where this is
zero and also where the partial
derivative of F with respect to Y at
that same point XY is equal to zero
so the idea is that this is going to
give us some kind of system of equations
that we can solve for x and y so let's
go ahead and actually do that um in this
case the partial derivative with respect
to X we look up here and the only places
where X shows up we have X to the fourth
minus four x squared so that X to the
fourth turns into four times X cubed
minus four x squared that becomes minus
8x and then y y just looks like a
constant so we're adding a constant and
nothing changes here so the first
requirement is that this portion is
equal to zero now the second part where
we're looking for the partial derivative
with respect to Y the only place where Y
shows up is this is this Y squared term
so the partial derivative with respect
to Y is just 2y and we're setting that
equal to zero and it shows a simple
example where these partial partial
derivative equations you know this one
nicely only includes X and this one
nicely only includes Y but that's not
always the case you can imagine if you
intermingle the variables a little bit
more these will actually kind of
intermingle X's and Y's and
be a harder thing to solve but I just
want something where we can actually
start to find the solutions so that's
free if we actually solve this system
this equation here the 2y equals zero
just gives us the fact that Y has to
equal zero so that's nice enough right
and then the second equation that 4x
cubed minus 8x equals zero
let's go ahead and rewrite that where
I'm going to factor out one of the X's
in factor out of 4 so this is 4 x
multiplied by x squared minus 2 has to
equal 0 so there's two different ways
that this can equal 0 right either X
itself is equal to 0 so that would be
one solution X is equal to 0 or x
squared minus 2 is 0 which would mean X
is plus or minus the square root of 2 so
we have X is plus or minus the square
root of 2 so the solution to the system
of equations we know that no matter what
Y has to equal 0 and then one of three
different things can happen x equals 0 x
equals positive square root of 2 or x
equals negative square root of 2 so this
gives us three separate solutions and
I'll go ahead and write them down our
three solutions as ordered pairs are
going to be either 0 0 4 when x is 0 and
Y is 0 you have a square root of 2 0 and
then you have negative square root of 2
0 these are the three different points
the three different values for x and y
that satisfy the two requirements that
both partial derivatives are 0 what that
should mean on the graph then is when we
look at those 3 different inputs all of
those have flat tangent planes so the
first one 0 0 if we kind of look above I
guess we're kind of inside the graph
here 0 0 is right at the origin and we
can see just looking at the graph that
that's actually a saddle point you know
this is neither a local maximum nor a
local minimum it doesn't look like a
peak or like a valley and then the other
two where we kind of move along the x
axis and I guess it turns out that this
point here is directly below x equals
positive square root of 2 and this other
minimum is directly below x equals
negative square root of 2 I would have
been able to guess that just looking at
the graph but we just figured it out
and we can see visually that both of
those are local minima but the question
is how could we have figure that out
once we find these solutions if you
didn't have the graph to look at
immediately how could you have figured
out that zero zero corresponds to a
saddle point in that both of these other
solutions correspond to local minima
well following the idea of the single
variable second derivative test what you
might do is take the second partial
derivatives of our function and see how
that might influence concavity for
example if we take the second partial
derivative with respect to X and I'll
Hall try to squeeze it up here second
partial derivative of the function with
respect to X we're doing that twice
we're taking the second derivative of
this expression with respect to X so we
bring down that three and that's going
to become 12 because three times four
times x squared 12 times x squared minus
eight minus eight so what this means
will kind of move that around what this
means in terms of the graph is that if
we move purely in the X direction which
means we kind of cut it with a plane
representing a constant Y value and we
look at the slice of the graph itself
this expression will tell us the
concavity at every given point so these
bottom two points here correspond to
plus and minus x equals the square root
of two so if we go over here and think
about the case where x equals the square
root of two and we plug that into the
expression what are we going to get well
we're going to get 12 x if x equals
square root of 2 then x squared is equal
to 2 so that's 12 times 2 minus 8 so
that's 24 minus 8 and we're going to get
16 which is a positive number which is
why you have positive concavity at each
of these points so as far as the
x-direction is concerned it feels like
yes both of these have positive
concavity so they should look like local
minima and then if you plug in 0 if
instead we went over here and we said x
equals 0 then when you plug that in
you'd have 12 times 0 minus 8 and
instead of 16 you would be getting
negative 8 so because you have a
negative amount that gives you this
negative concavity on the graph which is
why as far as X is concerned the origin
looks like a local maximum
so let's actually write that down if we
kind of go down here and we're analyzing
each one of these and we think about
what does it look like from the
perspective of each variable as far as X
is concerned that origin should look
like a max and then each of these two
points it should look like minima this
is kind of what the variable X thinks
and then the variable Y if we do
something similar and we take the second
partial derivative with respect to Y
y'all go ahead and write that over here
because this will be pretty quick second
partial derivative with respect to Y
we're taking the derivative of this
expression with respect to Y and that's
just a constant that's just 2 and
because it's positive it's telling you
that as far as Y is concerned there's
positive concavity everywhere and on the
graph what that would mean that would
mean if you just look at things where
you're kind of slicing with a constant
x-value to see pure movement in the Y
direction there's always going to be
positive concavity and here I've only
drawn the plane where X is constantly
equal to 0 but if you imagine kind of
sliding that plane around left and right
you're always getting positive concavity
so as far as Y is concerned everything
looks like a local minimum so we kind of
go down here and you'd say everything
looks like a local minimum minimum
minimum and minimum so it might be
tempting here to think that you're done
to think you found all the information
you need to because you say well in the
X and y direction they disagree about
whether that origin should be a maximum
or a minimum which is why it looks like
a saddle point and then they agree they
agree on the other two points that both
of them should look like a minimum which
is why you know which is why you could
say you think you might say both of
these guys look like a minimum however
that's actually not enough there are
cases there are examples that I could
draw we're doing this kind of analysis
would lead you to the wrong conclusion
you would conclude that certain points
are you know a local minimum when in
fact they're a saddle point and the
basic reason is that you need to take
into account information given by that
other second partial derivative because
in the multi variable world you can take
the partial derivative with respect to
one variable and then with respect to
another and you have to take into
account this
next partial derivative term in order to
make full conclusions and I'm a little
bit afraid that this video might be
running long so I'll cut it short here
and then I will give you the second
partial derivative test in its full
glory accounting for this mixed partial
derivative term in the next video and
I'll also you know give intuition for
where this comes in why it comes in why
this simple analysis that we did in this
case is closed and it does give
intuition but it's not not quite full
and it won't give you the right
conclusion always all right I will see
you then